The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or
view additional materials
from hundreds of
MIT courses, visit
mitopencourseware@ocw.mit.edu.
JULIAN BEINART: The piece that
I've had handed out to you
covers the trajectory that
we will follow from 1 to 7.
Let me make a comment
about the formal structure
of these examples.
The grid is a
universal language.
It is used in the cosmic
model in Xi'an in 190 BC.
And it's used in the 1811
Manhattan extension plan.
The assumption is, if one
takes this too literally,
is that the grid
is a language which
can perform its function
in almost any context.
That is possibly true.
In each case, it requires
one to ask questions
about the nature of
the grid-- its context,
its size, its manifestation,
what the contemporary culture
was attempting to produce.
The commissioners who laid out
the 1811 Plan for Manhattan
spoke in terms of
trying to create
the most everyday
environment they could.
What does every
day mean to them?
They're the examples
of New Amsterdam,
the Dutch settlement, and
the British settlement,
which followed.
Wall Street, by the
way, was the separation
between the English
and Dutch settlements.
So the explanation for the
centralized cosmic order
of Xi'an and the
same or similar use
of a grid in
Manhattan many years
later with this second set
of plans or plans for grids
of many European center cities.
They're all grids,
but infinitely varied
in size and dimension.
The diagram is that of a
Bastide town in the southwest.
This one happens to be a town
which divides the blocks up
according to a
diagonal measurement.
I'll deal with that
move more carefully.
The next is a diagram,
a fictitious diagram,
of a Roman town showing
the rectangularity which
exists around the
tying of a central knot
by this subdivision
of the blocks
according to a
horizontal east-west line
and this north-south line,
the Decumanus and the Cardo.
And the second last--
the last is an example of
contemporary fascination
with linearity following the
notion of machine performance.
Henry Ford who probably
advocated assembly line
production more than any other
industrialist in modern times
when he wanted to make
his own city in Muscle
Shoals in Alabama, didn't
use a linear system.
Well, maybe-- there are very
few plans of Muscle Shoals.
But it was a long city
which really interfaced
agriculture and industry.
Ford's notion was
that America had
gone wrong in
building industrialism
without agriculture.
He's postured it for
Muscle Shoals, which I'll
discuss later in this class.
It's interesting.
Every person-- Henry Ford
said, anybody who works for me
should spend part of
his time in a garden
or in a creative agricultural
performance of some kind.
The example on the
second to last page,
Southwest Washington in
plan, and our first notion
that the city should be made up
over time by points of interest
based on the topography and
on a diagonalized system
of connection was
opposed by Jefferson.
Jefferson made an
earlier plan which
is very difficult
to decipher but is
longitudinal and rectangular.
L'Enfant is quoted here as
saying, how boring a grid plan
is.
"Grid plans are tiresome and
insipid, however, answerable
they may appear on
paper or seducing
as they may be on first
aspect to the eyes,"
compared to Alexandria
in 77, which
was a rectangular
plan, which was
occupied right
from the beginning
and worked
subsequently very well.
So one of the aspects
of the machine model,
which this seems to
suggest, is that it has
a very high speed of return.
You can have a plan in an
extreme situation, which
requires a minimal
amount of surveying.
It has a high aspect
of legibility.
According to Gestalt's
theorist of urban form,
they would say that it's
because there is only one angle
in a right angle intersection.
Any other intersection
involves more than one angle.
And the basic fundamental
law of visual economy,
would suggest that you
would prefer the security
of the right angle.
That is a linguistic assumption.
And it's probably got a meta
truth associated with it.
It's not the only reason
that this grid form
appears in the machine model.
The cosmic model, which
we discussed last time,
put forward the ideal
of a crystalline city,
stable and hierarchical,
a magical microcosmos
in which each part was fused
into a perfectly ordered whole.
If it changed at all, it did
so only in this mechanical--
not in mechanical--
rhythmical, ordered,
completely unchanging way.
Thinking of the city as a
practical machine on their own
is an utterly
different conception.
A machine also has
permanent parts,
but the parts move
and move each other.
The machine can change,
although it does so
in some clearly predictable way.
Stability is inherent in
the parts, not necessarily
in the whole.
A whole grows by addition.
The wider meaning is simply
the sum of its parts.
It can be taken apart,
put together in reverse.
Its pieces can be replaced.
It is factual, functional,
cool, not magical at all.
This is a very basic statement,
that you can arm machine
with magical
properties is perfectly
possible for the human brain.
We will see in
the later examples
where, in fact, this is an
aspect of the machine model
which appears much later.
In its earliest
times, it's very pure.
The machine model occurs
historically most often
when its settlements are
temporary, secondly when
they have to be built
in haste or being
built for clear,
limited practical aims.
The expansion of Manhattan
North of Houston Street
invoked no magical properties.
When the Rockefellers intervened
and built Rockefeller Center,
there was some sense they did
so partly, historians claim,
to maintain the hegemony
over that part of Manhattan
where their house was.
Rockefeller Center
can be seen to fit
into the overall machine-like
system of Manhattan,
yet on its own it evokes
larger cultural invocation.
We'll talk more about that as
we talk later on in this class
about some of this.
I said, it's most useful
in temporary situations
when the environment
is built in haste,
when it's built for clear of
limited practical purposes.
But it's also used to allocate
land and resources quickly.
There's a kind of built-in idea
of equal distribution in mind
as well.
You'll recall
Marx's comment which
I made at the
beginning of the class
about the emerging distinction
between country and city.
What emerges as
urbanization occurs
is increasing gap in land
value between anything
that's urbanized and
anything that ruralized.
To pay back the enormous
investment in labor,
the Romans, for
instance, paid back
veterans who served
in the army by land.
It needed to subdivide the
land in an equitable fashion.
The word in English "lot,"
it refers to a plot of land
has the same root
as the word lottery.
The lottery was used
quite extensively
in this equalization.
So the machine model becomes
a checkerboard in some sense
in which you can give people
the promise of land value,
but you cannot exactly
initiate a central point.
There may be a central point
the crossing of the Cardo
and Decumanus, but that would
be reserved for the Roman Forum,
not for private land.
In the Laws of the
Indies, Los Angeles,
the last of the Laws of in the
Indies cities in the United
States, the Central Plaza
was 200 by 400 feet.
And then the grid
spread out from that.
So this notion of a democratic
distribution of urban land
is fundamentally in the process
of urbanizing at low cost--
conditional low cost.
The cosmic model required
enormous investments
in defense.
The first set of examples we
look at are the Egyptian slave
quarters built to
promote the eternal life
of the pharaonic
cult. For reasons
which are rather obscure,
Egypt was not accompanied.
Egypt's development
from 3,000 BC onwards
didn't involve
internecine warfare,
which meant that no
investment need to be made
in wars to defend a local site.
Once you invest
in the local site
and pay for the cost of
fortification, you don't move.
Cairo was a much
later phenomenon.
In the 3,000 years
until about 600 BC,
there were no cities in Egypt.
Thebes and Memphis were
only temporary cities.
They were built to enable the
construction of the metamorph--
not metamorphosis-- the
metaphysical structures
for the post-life
of the pharaoh.
It took so much
human labor to build
one of these cosmic structures
that the idea of labor and cost
and materials didn't go
into anything which we would
describe as a normal city.
It went instead
into the business
of construction and the
environment for the afterlife.
Yet that piece of the
pharaonic complex,
which housed the laborers,
were based on a per striga
system of block
development, which
we'll show you in the slide.
But--
AUDIENCE: I have
a question there.
JULIAN BEINART: Yes.
AUDIENCE: If I wanted
to make of these cities
the amount of resources
that you have invested,
both in time and
effort, that cements
the population [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART: Sure, sure.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE],, how
does it work in cities like--
I'm thinking of
Teotihuacan in Mexico,
Fatehpur Sikri in India,
that for this vast complex
that eventually they--
JULIAN BEINART: Both
of them disappeared.
Fatehpur Sikri
disappeared because
of a fundamental problem
of water, a miscalculation
of the amount of
salt in the water,
which caused the city to be--
prior to modern times few
cities have disappeared.
Fatehpur Sikri is one of them.
Teotihuacan under Mexican rule
became a tourist artifact.
The Aztec religion was
no more fundamental
after the Spanish hegemony.
So it lost its
fundamental purpose.
We don't lose citizens
easily anymore.
And that is an argument will
come about later in this class.
But bear in it mind,
the death of cities
is really a phenomenon
of pre-modern times.
And both examples
you give, in the one
lost its fundamental
mechanical system.
Salty water is no longer the
basis for a wonderful town
that Fatehpur Sikri was.
And Teotihuacan didn't
have an adaptive mechanism
to sustain its growth.
It was no reason for it to grow.
Tenochtitlan, on the other
hand, had all of the capacity
as a capital city on the lake.
The combination of
the mysterious quality
of the original-- of
the landing of the eagle
in the center of the cosmos.
That was taken over as
an astronomic-- anyway,
we'll talk more about this.
You raised an
interesting argument.
According to the fifth century
Greek historian Herodotus
told--
I don't know how he knew
this, but 100,000 men
were engaged for
three months each year
for 20 years in moving blocks
of stone to a pharaonic site.
He claims that
there must have been
something like
4,000 workers which
had to be housed permanently.
So Leonard Woolley
the archaeologist
writing about Tell el-Amarna
describes the housing
as monotonously alike, each with
its kitchen parlor in front,
its cupboards and
bedrooms behind,
the very patina of mechanically
devised industrial building.
Same arguments made by
other archaeologists.
The distinction between
enslavement of labor and cultic
objectives is characteristic
of this Egyptian phenomenon.
A more elaborate system
of using the machine model
takes place in
Hellenistic towns.
In colonial situations,
it's very unlikely
that the mother city
will be replicated
in the colonial system.
Delhi is not like London.
The Laws of the Indies towns,
Bogota, is not like Madrid.
Athens had its own
unique structure.
It was an Iraqi site.
It had limited
agricultural resources.
And it needed to expand as part
of its Mediterranean expansion
to the south to Africa,
to the east to Asia Minor,
and to the west eventually to
Sicily and to Southern Italy.
The building of
colonial empire took
place not because of the
advantages of the mother city.
In fact, fifth century
democracy in Athens
is unlikely to have been spread.
There's one theory that
says the Greek islands
or the Greek colonial sites--
not islands-- were the result
of the expansion of democracy.
Democracy only occurred
in the first century BC.
The colonial expansion
of the Greeks
prior to that,
the most important
of the colonial towns,
the grid-like towns,
was built in 479 by the planner
Hippodamus, who had a stutter,
he had long hair, and had
interesting political theories.
He discovered the method
of dividing cities
and cut up Pireas.
He's also known
by some historians
as the inventor of the
gridiron and the father
of town planning.
Hippodamus, 479, Miletus--
this was the first time
that a town was considered as
a totality in a certain sense.
All the parts of the
town were in place,
except perhaps for industry.
One doesn't know
from archaeology
how much industry took place
in these colonial times.
They were essentially
trading towns.
Mumford argues that
the grid serves
as a method for making form of
clarity of international trade.
There's something to
be said for having
a recognizable or legible
environment as you
move into new environments.
You put your stamp on a place.
It's almost like building a
Hilton Hotel, which hardly
serves to emulate
the environment
or to affect the environment.
But Mumford's argument is
that modern trade requires
a standardization of commodity.
He later on, in talking about
American grid of expediency,
refers to capitalism and
the grid of expediency
as phenomenally correct
and absolutely connected.
Whether this is
true, we will discuss
as we go through this class.
There's no absolute connection
between capitalist theory
and grid phenomena.
I'll speak to this point
a bit later in this class.
The other towns of
distinction were
Olynthus in the Northern
Greek peninsula.
Oh no, it's not on
the peninsula-- it's
further north, north of Athens.
And Priene, 300 BC.
All of these involve
the same phenomena
shaped within the grid.
And agora, a wall, a
wall didn't conform
to the grid-like system.
These towns were built
on defensible sites
so that the wall system was
informal and took account
of the minimum ways of building
infrastructure on sloping land.
The British architect Peter
Smithson in a talk on the BBC
once argued against the
classical vocabulary of Greece.
He of course, is
an architect who
very interested in informalism.
And he argued that
one should really
look at the Greek fortifications
as a structure for one's
intellectual heritage rather
than the classical system
of the Greeks.
Cartilaginous whether he's right
or wrong, and he won't tell us.
There is no central axis made by
the intersection of major axis.
The agora was at the center.
The grid was exemplified, again,
as a grid of absolute equality.
These towns have had lives
beyond the Greek time.
They were taken by Hellenism,
by Romans, and most of them
disappeared.
They couldn't withstand-- the
requirements have changed.
Greece was replaced as a
power in the Mediterranean
and [INAUDIBLE] disappeared.
But I have referred to Mumford.
He says, I quote, "a new
regularity and system
in commercial affairs
causes a formal order
that when you are faced with
the presence of a hill or curved
bay, there's no
effort to adaptation
for change of pattern."
A similar phenomenon
occurs in the Roman Empire.
I'm just going
through these things
very quickly because
we're limited in time.
Each of these examples has
a literature available.
If any of you want to follow the
particular literature involved,
just send me an email and
I'll send you the references.
It's impossible in a class like
this to go into the details
more than the
general description.
You have to assume that the
generalizations are correct.
It's my fault if they wrong.
Built cities in an empire--
there was no empire to the
extent in the world's history
prior to the Roman
Empire, not in scale.
The Romans built something
like 5,627 towns.
Towns were often
at the intersection
of important points.
Her empire stretched
from Scotland to Slovakia
to the Middle East
to North Africa.
Again, some of the same
phenomena occurred.
Timgad, the great Roman
town in North Africa,
is a town for veterans.
It's subdivided
into equal blocks
to repay veterans for service.
There are two characteristics
of a Roman town.
Again, the same phenomenon
of the commercial order,
of an international
commercial order,
creating the logic for formal
order or local formal order.
Germanicus, the
Roman, general says,
"I can feel I'm
still in Rome if I
journey from London or the
beginning of London, Londinium,
to Rome."
The poet Rutilius Namatianus
says, "a city of the far flung
Earth you have made."
So there are two compunctions
in the Roman city.
The one is to create a locus,
a place of significance,
much like a camp.
For that already the
connections to the space outside
of the town is made by
emphasizing the Cardo
and Decumanus system.
We have the Greek town,
much like the magical town
before it.
It was an isolated
phenomenon sitting
on often very complex territory,
and building a wall which
fitted the territory's form.
And although there may be a port
here, as in the case of Priene,
there was no attempt to
connect this to anything else.
There was no empire
large enough.
The Roman town was
an empire town.
The Cardo and Decumanus
centralized in a forum
and was an version of
an encampment which
could be built anywhere.
It's the basis of London,
it's the basis of Paris,
it's the basis of
Bratislava, it's
the basis of 5,000 settlements.
That's A. And we call
this castrametation,
a nominal phenomenon.
That is to logically extend
the marking of the territory
outside the town.
This is called centuriation.
Sorry, you can't read my
handwriting-- castrametation,
centuriation.
That is the measuring of land
outside the town by a surveying
technique using a gromaticus,
a manual on utility
needs how to lay
out parcels of land.
These were both used for
agricultural purposes
and also as payment for service.
So the hermetic quality of
the Greek colonial settlement
is quite different in spirit.
Every crossing was a town.
The notion of being
the center of a empire
is different than the
metaphysics of being
the center of the Earth.
The one is provable,
the one is not provable.
The one is metaphysical,
as in the cosmic model.
You'll remember my
quoting Vassiliadis
regarding the centeredness
of the archaic world.
The centeredness
here is the linking.
Of course, the center of
Rome, with all its fora
and magnificence, was the
center of a fundamental system
of financial distribution.
The Roman Empire was
built on physicality.
That is, on the learning how
to tax people locally, and then
feed the money back
into a central place.
This is the first model
of colonial enterprise.
You find some wonderful
reactions to it.
Bellini's opera Norma--
has anybody seen Norma?
You should see Norma.
Norma is the story of
the Roman occupation
of the capital city of Gaul.
And Norma is the
local woman who leads
the revolt against the Romans.
She of course falls in love
with a Roman lieutenant.
And both of them disappear
into the God only knows what.
Or if you want another
invocation of the Roman city,
read Shakespeare's
play Coriolanus.
Coriolanus is a bad Roman
and he suffers on his attempt
to return to Rome to
his mother center,
but fails in his attempt.
OK, there's a lot to be
said about the Romans.
The territory subdivided by the
gromaticus is generally 6 by 6,
or 36 units.
And this is the
circumference of land
plowed by one ox in one day.
I'm wanting to go through
this very quickly because we
have to look at some images
and there's no point.
I'm only trying to make a
central an argument as I
can about each case.
One of the arguments
I'm not making
is the influence of materials.
The Romans were the first
people to invent concrete.
And the public quality
of the Roman city
is ascribed to the
availability of concrete.
For those of you
interested, there's
is a piece by an MIT
Professor, Heather Lechtman
called Roman Concrete and the
Roman Architecture Revolution.
She argues that
hydraulic setting cement
was an attractive ceramic
medium for a period buildings.
These could be processed
at ambient temperatures
from readily available
raw ingredients
and cast into large,
designated spaces.
It produced integral
monolithic structures,
which could be
incrementally extended.
The Greeks had to meet
in the open space.
The Jews still meet
in the open space
up against the Western
Wall against the remnants
of Herod's Temple.
The Romans for the
first time made
it possible to enclose
space and convert the spaces
is no larger than about six
feet enormities corridor
is a very concrete phenomenon.
The Pantheon is an example.
But Lechtman doesn't only
refer to the Pantheon.
She refers to the aqueducts,
to the whole system
of building public buildings
at the scale that they did.
The Greeks weren't
great builders.
They were aesthetes.
There's a thesis last year by
Daniele Cappelletti who argues
that the Romans enabled the
beginning of what he called
[INAUDIBLE] architecture--
that is, the interior
of buildings.
The Greeks weren't
interested in interiors--
they were exterior,
externalizers.
A plan of the agora
doesn't follow any access.
It's a jumble of things,
much like the Mayan town.
If you devote yourself to
creating buildings which only
makes sense given the
exterior, what they can see
or how they can be seen, you
can deviate from the model
that the Romans used.
The post-Roman period,
we call the Middle Ages.
In my learning of history,
these were the Dark Ages.
Nothing happened--
the world only
emerged after a period of
immense turmoil in Europe.
There's been recent history done
on this period from 300 to 900
AD, from 400 to 880 AD,
to mention two new books.
There's not too much to be said.
The Roman system was
localized in every respect.
Large families and the
church took over sites
from Roman camps.
The fiscal system-- there wasn't
a centralized economy funding
taxation into Rome,
so each set up
a competitive system for towns.
One of the things that
the Roman roads did
was to allow the subsequent
cultures to use the system
of moving large distances.
The Christian Church
took advantage of this.
In the story of [INAUDIBLE]
what's the town in the--
my mind has slipped--
the town I wrote about
in the first reading?
It's [INAUDIBLE] one of the
saintly cities in Northern
Spain, [INAUDIBLE] named--
AUDIENCE: Compostela
JULIAN BEINART: Compostela.
Of course, it's
named after James.
It's got the same name as San
Diego and all of the-- sorry,
I try to remember too much.
Pilgrimage was made possible
by virtue of the Roman roads,
so was in medieval
connections in commerce.
A pilgrim could come to
Compostela from Bulgaria,
walk or take a donkey,
move through France
where they would stay
in religious hostels,
eat Coquilles
Saint-Jacques, which
is the food which emanates from
Compostela, because Compostela
is a signature in the scallop,
much like shell petroleum.
It adopted the scallop
as its important logo.
I think the first
post-medieval notion
of the machine-like
phenomenon occurs
with the expansion
in the 13th century
of the French Bastide towns.
Bastides is B-A-S-T-I-D-E-S.
In the 13th century,
the Central Royal Authority
built something like 177 new
towns in the French
territory in the south.
Between 1241 and
1330, you have towns
like Carcassonne, Beauvais,
Montpensier, [INAUDIBLE]..
These settlers who were asked
to come and populate these towns
were there because of the
French authority's wish
to propose to defend,
imposed their will
on the distant
parts of the empire.
They also developed
as markets centers.
A grid of convenience,
the quickest
and most equitable way of
laying out a town on a new site.
The form of these towns
is also grid-like.
The plan differs in some
fundamental respects.
The plan is a formal order
which is generally orthogonal.
But the plan, it doesn't
follow the Roman preoccupation
with a single axis.
It pairs roads.
This is the central square.
And where the road passes
through the central square,
it is arcaded.
The church is generally
located on a side site.
These sites was subdivided
in grid fashion.
There's a gate here, a gate
here, there's a gate here,
and there's a gate here.
And the same impulse to make
it attractive for people
to migrate, to pay them for the
effort of migration, the state
takes on the role of building
the walls, and so on.
Has any of you been
to a town like this?
Which town do you remember?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
JULIAN BEINART:
Well, Montpensier
is probably the best known.
It has the most developed
system of arcades.
If you have any chance to
visit Montpensier, do so.
The wine is good.
The arcades are called cornier.
And the subdivision
of the land is
called in French it's
referred to as checkers.
And popular game checkers
has similar notation,
formal notation, as
the layout of the town.
By the way, Winston
Churchill's house
was named Checkers as well.
Haven't the faintest idea
why, but it's amusing.
The largest decentralization
after the Roman
occurs in the Spanish
occupation of Latin America
and the southern part
of the United States.
This is about a crude
a generalization as one
could make, but I'll try.
In 1494, the Meridian
of Tordesillas
is divided Latin America
into Portuguese domain
and the Spanish domain.
The Laws of the Indies
applies to this domain here
and also to this domain
here, which was part
of South America at the time.
We'll talk about the
grid of expediency here
and the cattaneo model here.
C-A-T-T-A-N-E-O-- New
Haven, Savannah, Charleston.
Let's makes
generalizations about them.
In 1573, Philip
II, understanding
the military, religious, and
financial availability of land
in the hinterland
of the Americas,
created an argument or set
of principles on which towns
would be laid out.
These are called in English
the Laws of the Indies.
They describe the way you are
set of rules which specify--
I'd better hurry-- the size
of the individual components
of the town.
The main plaza
was to be oriented
so its four corners
pointed to the four
cardinal points of a compass.
It shall not be smaller
than 200 feet wide
and 300 feet long, no larger
than 800 feet long, and so on.
It had a formal
message to convey
to the Indians who located
around where the new settlement
tool place.
"When the Indians see them, they
will be filled with wonder."
That is the church.
The Indians should not
be let into this town
until the church is finished.
The church architecture
represents the formal attribute
of colonial superiority.
The Indians must understand
that they have been conquered
by a superior race,
therefore the church,
which is to the
Spanish the highest
form of contact with God and
the only formal attribute
that we have other than
behavior and ritual,
becomes the temple of
the Roman town, at least
to the Laws of the Indies town.
St. Augustine, Florida
was the first application
of the Laws of the
Indies in 1565.
Los Angeles was the last of
the Spanish settlements, 1781.
So the period of
this 1565 to 1781
takes care of many of
the towns, St. Augustine.
The Anglo-American grid, which
is the grid of experience
to the North, overlaps with
the Laws of the Indies grid
in towns like Albuquerque.
If you want to look further
into how this structure works
when the two collide, I'll
give you the reference.
It's a piece written
by an ex-student
from this class published
a number of years ago.
The Portuguese Empire
was left to develop
according to a pattern different
from the Spanish towns.
The Portuguese
Empire was casual.
It really spent
most of its presence
in the Iberian Peninsula
looking outwards and being
dramatic, reoriented, and
conquering the sea routes.
Sao Paulo, which is now one
of the world's largest cities,
one of the few 20
million-person cities,
has its origin in
nothing more than three
different religious sects
forming the town on a hill
away from the water.
Sao Paulo should have
been on the water.
These people made a
mistake, and in competition
with each other set up
three points of growth
in central Sao Paulo.
AUDIENCE: How do
the Law of Indies
apply to a city
like Mexico City,
because it was actually
kind of established.
JULIAN BEINART: It adapted.
Most of these
generalizations and rules
are systems of order which have
to compete with the existing
structure.
The Greek town, had
it been in the desert,
would have been paid
less attention to it.
The Egyptian town,
being on the flat land,
didn't deal with topography.
The story of Mexico
is a long story,
and I haven't got time
unfortunately to--
maybe I can send you
an email about it.
But the story of Mexico City.
Where are you from.
AUDIENCE: I'm from Mexico.
JULIAN BEINART: Where?
AUDIENCE: So I know
the story of Mexico.
What I'm trying to
understand is how
it deviated from one
standardized town
the photos and another.
JULIAN BEINART: It followed
it as best it could.
One needs to look
at Bogota or Quito
to find much more pure example--
I'm sure both Bogota
and Quito are much purer
examples of building
new towns on the basis
of little competition.
Mexico City was unusual.
Most of the Laws of the
Indies towns were new towns.
OK, let's jump.
The amount of time
left for discussing
the influences on the laying
out of most of Central--
not Central America,
Central and North America--
can be found in books by
John Rep's Town Planning
in Frontier America,
a number of texts.
One of the best that I would
refer to is Conzen's writing.
The reference isn't
in this class,
it's for class number 24.
Conzen, a British
geographer, has
written very excellent stuff.
Essentially the components
of the grid of expediency
are the following--
number 1, the Land
Ordinance of 1785
which divided the unbuilt
parts of the United States,
first only part of
it, then finally
most of the United States,
into a grid of 6 by 6 miles.
Local authorities or
local towns could then
subdivide within this grid.
Most of the subdivision was
taken care of by two forces,
either private development,
which subdivided length
into smaller units, or the
railroad companies which
merged [INAUDIBLE] develop
[INAUDIBLE] profits
hand-in-hand.
The standard plan used
by railroads for 33 towns
developed by one group
alone in Illinois.
There was another
force at work, and that
was the movement of religious
groups such as the Mormons
across this country.
There were Mormons starting
in 1913 up in New York.
They moved to a Kirkland, Ohio,
they were pushed out of there.
They move to Missouri,
the revelation
that this is the new place.
They moved out of there.
They went to Nauvoo in Illinois
and spent the winter quarters
in 1847 in Nebraska.
And finally in 1847, after
a journey of 17 years,
Brigham Young said,
this is the place
and he developed Salt Lake City.
Salt Lake City is a grid city,
which has a set of micro-rules
about street--
which lots can be facing
the streets, and so on.
I'll talk about that later.
Two people who've argued
about the grid of expediency--
Lewis Mumford has
called urban land
becoming a mere commodity
by the parceling of land
a quick conversion of
farmstead into real estate
and a quick sale.
Richard Sennett has written
in the Conscience of the Eye
about the Protestant
ethic of being
satisfied with what he calls
the Protestant ethic of space.
"Here is where the
good found its place.
It was a space for
economic competition
to be played upon
like a chessboard.
It was a space of neutrality,
and neutrality achieved
by denying to the environment
any value of its own."
This attempt to
argue in this way
argues that, if I
buy any IBM share,
I buy a piece of
its typewriters--
I don't know if they
still makes them--
a piece of real estate,
a piece of its land.
My $5 share, or $47
share, is a commodity
as a reduction of a
large complex whole.
The argument is that the
city is a complex whole.
And reducing it to a
commodity by gridding it
takes no account of the
essential qualities of a city.
There's a kind of cosmic memory
associated with his critique.
How capitalism developed
Boston with no grid
is, of course, a question
I would ask Richard Sennett
or Lewis Mumford.
Not all American cities
were like Chicago.
The cattaneo of cities
on the East Coast,
I have got time to--
but they essentially
are best described
by the Plan of Savannah, written
very elegantly in an analysis
by Stanford Anderson, who's
a Professor in the Department
of Architecture.
It essentially
takes the grid plan
and centers it
into neighborhoods
with parks in the center.
It divides the road
system into wider roads
which run north-south.
Why do the roads in Manhattan
are wider, 100 feet wide,
going north-south, and 50
feet wide going east-west?
What are the roads
connecting in the Rome sense?
Docks, water traffic on
either side of the island.
So the east-west street
should have been wider
than the north-south street.
The north-south are avenues.
Why?
Let's try to answer
that question
in talking about the 1811 Plan.
The 1811 Plan was
no cosmic plan.
According to Roy
Strickland's writing,
it simply adapted
the measurements
of the British
settlement, which took
over the Dutch original
1623 settlement.
There was a wonderful exhibition
of the 1811 Plan in New York
last year.
I don't know if
any of you saw it.
Did you see it?
Pretty.
It says more than
I can possibly say.
In the commissioner's
report, it says,
"we could not bear in
mind that a city is
to compose principally of
the habitations of men,
and that straight-sided
and right-angled houses
are the most cheap to build and
the most convenient to live in,
effective these plain and simple
reflections are decisive."
So here we have a plan which
many people have commented on,
a plan which is allowed enormous
subdivisional specialization,
a plan which has allowed
the southern sector to grow
as a financial center.
A central part is a part
for department stores,
the combination of
housing and offices
and commerce in the
rest of the plan.
Essentially, it's a plan which
[INAUDIBLE] has correctly
written about as delirious.
One of the advantages
of a free system.
There have been rules about
building a Manhattan ever
since, the protection
of the sidewalks--
the height at
which buildings get
build, and so on, over time.
But the central
grid has remained.
It is fundamental to the
grid system of New York
that Central Park
connects east and west.
The grid system is the
fundamental flexibility
phenomenon of Manhattan.
And it coupled with
the combination
of income and density
produces a unique situation
which we will examine more
carefully later in this class.
But could Manhattan be developed
on a different principle
than a grid?
That's asking a big question.
We'd have to do
different plans for that
and try to assemble the
conjecture that follows.
We're not doing it, and
it's ridiculous to do it.
The lessons from
Manhattan are to be
learned by virtue of
reading the original plan
and studying the
attempts to modify it.
It like many-- how are we doing?
Two minutes-- like
many city plans,
is in a constant
state of adaptation.
The Second Avenue
Subway is the last
of the most recent of
the distortions of--
not the distortions,
that adaptations
to the plan, the attempt to--
Rowe Price Manhattan
failed, it's probably
likely to occur at sometime.
The impossibility of connecting
the hinterland to the center
is evidenced by the
fact that New York, one
of the primary commercial
cities of the world,
has the worst international
airport system of any city
competitively.
It's only the
arrogance of New York
that let's it get away with
having a second rate airport
system.
Those of who have experienced
LaGuardia and Kennedy and New
Jersey and have been
to great, new airports
can argue for yourselves
the distinction.
Carnegie Hall is one of the
most uncomfortable places
to listen to great music.
Again, New York gets
away through a kind
of economic arrogance.
The theory, which is highly
personal to me, that is,
if you develop enough
economic strength,
you need not follow it by
making everything of the highest
order.
It's a stupid phenomenon,
but maybe it's true.
It's only in China, which
has new wealth, that people
can build new airports.
It's of course not totally true.
But one of the major concerns
about the additive quality
of the Chinese city is that
it is a city of addition
and has lost any of the
attributes of the cosmos
or even the Roman camp.
We will go into that some more.
The last group of
slides will deal
with the evocation of linearity
and more modern concepts
of the use of the
idea of the machine.
So why don't we look at them,
otherwise we will just go on.
This is a long class.
This is an enormous
amount of stuff.
I don't apologize for
these first three classes.
Most you haven't done
enough urban history.
Here are two examples.
The one on the right
is from Tell el-Armana.
The one on the left is from
Kahun 2460 BC and 320 BC.
Next.
This is the town
of Tell el-Amarna
on the east side of the Nile
built by the Pharaoh Akhenaten
and occupied for only 40 years.
He had a religious argument
with the priest in Thebes
and went across the Nile
to build his new town.
The yellow in the plan
refers to the workers lair.
There's another story,
which I haven't got time
much to go into that.
In Freud's writing
about Moses, the book
is called Moses
and Monotheism, he
talks about the connection
between pharaonic Egypt
and the emergence of
Palestine, the sum notion
that this land for Jerusalem
is taken from the Dead Sea
Scrolls.
The sum notion that there
was some connection passing
on information
from the Jevasites,
the first occupiers of
Jerusalem, or one of the first,
and the Egyptians.
Next.
The Greek town, Miletus--
Miletus, you can
see the structure
of the containing wall.
The orange and darker colors
of the imposition of the Romans
on top of the Greek plan.
Next.
OK, Priene, the
main axes roads--
again north-south with
minor roads east-west,
and the central agora
complex and temple complex
and part of the central
parts of the town.
The Roman road system, an
extraordinary phenomenon.
Just imagine at
the birth of Christ
or a couple of hundred
years afterwards
that there'd be an empire
built as significantly
connected as this.
This gives some indication
of the location of the Roman
towns--
5,627 according
to one authority.
Next.
castrametation, the
idea of the town
as being cemented by
two connecting roads,
a fortification
around the outskirts,
and the notion of a
gridded system outside.
It takes an enormous
amount of thought
to imagine a town which
has a fortification having
a counterpart formal
order outside the town.
That is unique to the Romans.
They were so conscious of
the clarity of the empire
that they could imagine
making the land--
again, the land as opposed to
the city in marks, the land
as a friend of the city.
Next.
Here is the 6 by 6 system
of land subdivision
for an ox which can
perambulate in one day
the layout made by a [INAUDIBLE]
at the hands of a gromaticus.
Here near [INAUDIBLE]
in Central Italy,
you can see some of the effects
even today of the length
of the centuriation pattern.
The city is only in
existence in its relationship
to this space outside it as it
is condensed in its interior.
It's a phenomenal idea.
It's an idea which
American cities have not,
or modern cities, have
not understood completely.
Next.
Timgad, the great Roman city
for veterans on North Africa.
The Cardo and Decumanus
here are shortened
because of the location of the
forum and the amphitheater.
Next.
Two plans-- Verona on the
right and the first attempt
in a relatively Renaissance plan
of Florence based on attempts
to introduce a local
taxation system
and still respecting
the Roman grid.
Next.
The southwest of France--
the Bastide town,
a pair of towns.
The cornier in the center,
the church on the side.
Next.
[SPEAKING FRENCH] Here you
see something interesting
geometrically.
The blocks as they go
further from the center
have the horizontal length
based on the diagonal
of the previous.
So the blocks get
bigger as you go out.
It's a geometric trick.
Here it is.
Next.
[INAUDIBLE] the great
town on the Mediterranean,
clearly in prismatic.
This served is one
of the launching
points for many crusades
to Christianize Jerusalem.
And here's [INAUDIBLE]
one of the roads running
through the central
plaza, a cornier
system of creating
a greater pedestrian
opportunity in the center.
It's like building a permanent
arcade around the center.
Next.
Here's the Meridian
of Tordesillas--
the Spanish world and
the North American world.
Here's a typical Laws
of the Indies town.
I think it's Caracas
central plaza.
Next.
In contrast, the development
of the typical Portuguese town,
as you can see from
its early stages,
has developed long strips.
Next.
Again, this is-- thank you.
This is a thesis done
on examining the Laws
of the Indies in detail.
It's a thesis here at MIT
by Guillermo Frontado.
He looks at the
streets at the plazas
and interprets the
laws in formal terms--
what distances they occupy,
what sections they produce,
and so on.
Next.
So here is the
subsequent development
of two central capital
Latin American cities based
on the Laws of the Indies.
Here are the major churches
on the central plaza.
Here you see the adaptation
of the central plaza
theme in subsequent
decentralized plazas.
Next.
Subdivision of the 6
by 6 mile 1785 system.
Next.
Salt Lake City,
Harrington, Kansas--
built the railway company.
Next.
Chicago, which we'll deal
with in some detail later on.
And Burnham's Plan
1907, 1905 Plan
to centralize the
grid of Chicago.
It's an extraordinary
plan, diagonalizing
the grid towards the center.
It's kind of attempt
cosmetize Chicago.
Next.
1811 Plan.
Again, this is out of focus.
Now, why then change this.
The story of Central
Park is another story.
Next.
The inevitable connections
of the east and west,
maintaining the grid,
while still producing
a major public garden.
Next.
The cattaneo model-- that
is, dispersing open space
throughout the system and
having different widths of roads
is part of the system.
Next.
Savannah, Georgia--
still a marvelous town,
and a town which resisted here.
There's a book called
the Night of Garden.
What's the book?
Anybody know the book?
Which talks about
Savannah's decision
not to take large companies,
like insurance companies
as headquarters because
of their attempt
to keep the local system.
Next.
And a few of the
modern examples.
This is Soria y Mata,
the Spaniard's plan
for linearizing the outskirts
of Madrid, a linear model being
a very popular model,
taken essentially
from a mass fabrication system.
Next.
[INAUDIBLE] the affirming
steed, the magnificent steed,
the superb steed.
The engine of the express
train, the steam engine
which people went to see.
And the Ascoral Plan,
which Corbusier was one of,
1940, a plan to link
Europe, to linearize Europe.
Next.
Captain [? Chambliss's ?]
plan for linking New York
and Washington with a
public train system that
had an effect on
the local-- that
fed off the agricultural
land next to it.
Somebody called it a
horizontal skyscraper.
Kenzo Tange's 1960 plan
for the linearizing Tokyo
and creating a greater use
of the harbor, of the water.
Next.
Stupid plans like this by Jonah
Friedman to linearize Paris.
Absolute madness--
should lock people up.
Next.
The fascination with
bringing together
a number of mechanical forces--
train, bus, pedestrian,
and the many schemas
for maximizing
density in New York.
The stupidity of the
Archigram proposal for moving.
Archigram would have
worked very well in Egypt
where you had no investment
in permanent sites,
but you moved around.
This is the grasshopper
city, which moves around.
If there's anything we've
learned historically,
that the inertia of
cities in modern times
maintains this position.
I've said this before, that you
can count the number of cities.
There are cities in
trouble like Detroit,
but there's no disappearance
of cities, or very few,
compared to previous times.
Next.
It's called Buckminster
Fuller and notion
of using a single
machine to cover
the whole of the
city of Manhattan.
Next.
I think we end here.
This is Lord
Behrens' proposition
for the AEG factory--
just about done--
in Berlin showing
the wonderful correct place
for every worker in the system.
And here the nightmare of Soweto
outside Johannesburg, or part
of Johannesburg,
where race created
a new town in which the
machine model is exemplified
par excellence
with no pretension
paid to anything else but
the disposition of houses
in free space.
OK.